[Applaudissements]
c'est passé me suis focalisé moi j'adore
la version de crazy frappe alors où on a
on a nous a beaucoup parlé de barack
obama ce week end avec jean luc lemoine
ce que nous sommes allés en belgique
ensemble pour participer au télévie
exactement et et jean luc lemoine
sachez le à y perdre un bois voilà on
vous raconte tout c'est vrai mais il est
en tout cas il faut savoir qu on a eu la
chance d'être dans l'hôtel de barbie où
était passé barack obama ouais depuis ce
week-end maintenant 10 et l'hôtel où est
passée cyril hanouna
mais jean luc lemoine s'est coincé le
doigt voulons vous racontent tour il a
failli perdre un doigt et je suis monté
dans un taxi et j'ai mis ma main et le
garçon qui était devant a eu la bonne
idée de claquer des doigts et j'ai eu
mon doigt coincé dans la banque c'est à
dire que j'étais en train de mourir
vraiment et l'autre était mort de rire
hélas hélas j'ai eu cette phrase julie
frochot ixe qc un doigt me qu'il en a
bien 4
[Applaudissements]